la grande chose à propos de ce film est que
nous avons traversé la configuration du
monde un insurgé, nous réalisons à quel point
le monde est vraiment grand
dans une action passionnante avec de
grandes performances,
vous avez déjà tous les personnages
présentés maintenant, nous pouvons juste dire  une belle
histoire
tout de suite, nous allions commencer le film
avec de l'action avec Tris chassé de
faction en faction et ne jamais lâcher
depuis divergente, elle est devenue un peu
plus dure et un peu plus dure le film
commence avec Tris et quatre et une faction
appelée entité
un MIDI est  le groupe d'agriculteurs leur chemin
au bord de tout ce qu'ils apprécient la
compassion et la paix et ce n'est pas tout
à fait juste comme l'état d'esprit
et le sergent est aussi Sikandar vous voyez des
factionnaires là-bas ont marché sans
faction et il y a ce
chef puissant et c'est Kaname qu'est-ce qu'il
va jouer ma mère nous  besoin de plus de
soldats je sais où
se cachent les intrépides restants le genre de départ de chacun
de nos copains cinq génies dans ce
film Jeanine est prête  aller à n'importe quelle
limite pour obtenir exactement ce qu'elle veut que
veut-elle dire pense être dans cette clé de boîte je
ne sais pas mais elle teste diverge
la boîte prend beaucoup de mes
scènes préférées du livre et les met
au même endroit à  en même temps dans le
premier film, vous ne savez pas vraiment dans
quel domaine Dai se trouve
insurgé, c'est limpide commençons
donc un film a toutes sortes de sirops et
un parfum incroyablement intense
et les effets visuels sont hallucinants
alors vous le faites  un film d'action d'une manière que vous
connaissez pour que vous puissiez faire des trucs amusants
j'ai évidemment un accent mais celui-ci
est passé au niveau supérieur c'est un
film d'action très ambitieux mais allons-y
en divergent nous avons créé un monde en
insurgé nous allons estragon
vous